で そこでこのモノと時空関係について
モノは成り立たないという結論
いつでも時空で考えましょうと
だから あの すぐ忘れちゃう
忘れるならば この例を覚えてください
おにぎりは美味しいですか？というではなくて
美味しいおにぎりがありましたよということですね
美味しいおにぎりがありますということがバツで
美味しいおにぎりが あので
1 2時まで 8時から 1 2時まで美味しいおにぎりがテーブルの上にありますはマルで
えーと 時間の時空次元だけで見る
仏教は時間という次元を何よりも重視する
それで今まで私は次元 2つを紹介してたんです
時空とタイムとスペース
しかし 仏教はそれを一つ取っちゃうんです
時間だけ で 一切の真理が立たないんです
仏教はもう経典 日本訳で読んで理解すること
そんな甘いものじゃありません
かなり厳しいんです 時間の次元
次元で真理を発見するんです
はい 次のポイント オブジェクトアンドイベントという
まあそれは日本語 日本語はないんです
オブジェクトは固定した変わらないもののことです
ものっていうのはオブジェクトなんですね
それでまた漢字がわかりやすくなったのは
これこそ覚えてほしいポイントなんです
イベントとはイベント
成り行きです イベントはその瞬間だけの成り行きで変わって消えてゆきます
だからオブジェクトはものだから変わって消えたっていうことはないでしょう
イベントは イベントはその瞬間だけ
だからイベントには必ずしも時空関係あるんです
あの 皆様普通に知ってるイベントという単語を理解で十分です
皆様 頭の中でいろんな今
いろんな今妄想が浮かんでいるでしょうに
イベントといえば何でしょうかね
皆さんが思っていることは正しいんです
イベントといえば あの時間が必要でしょ
イベントっていうのはずっとあるわけじゃないでしょ
蔵前の駅があるように
例えば蔵前の駅で明日日曜日 9時から 1 2時までイベントがあります
ですよ すべての事象はイベントです
これで仏教で言いたいことはそれなんです
本当は蔵前の駅っていうこともイベントなんです
蔵前の駅で明日 10 10時から 1 2時まであの生演奏をする何かイベントありますよと言ったっても
それもイベントです 駅もイベントです
私と言ったっても一つのイベントなんです
机と言ったっても一つのイベントなんです
だから すべての現象はモノでなくイベントであるということが
仏教から言いたいところなんです
モノではないのです 人にはわずかな出来事以外
すべてモノです 我々にとっては仏教じゃないんだから
我々にとっては まあわずかなものはイベントで
他全部モノで 例えば隅田川の花火大会やりますね
それはイベントで 1年一回ですですね
しかし 隅田川がモノです
ずっとあるんです それが我々の世界の思考
隅田川で起こるイベントは花火大会である
それは時空関係あります
どこで花火を打ち上げるのか
何時から何時までかという
その時見事に時空関係入りますね
だからイベントなら必ず時空関係が入るんです
ものならないんです 時空関係
それで今日頑張って理解してほしいのは
あの仏教を学ぶ 怠けたら仏教学べないんです
しょうがないんです 頑張らないと
今日頑張って学んでほしいポイントは
ものはないんだよと すべてイベントだよということなんです
例えば例なんですけど
結婚披露宴は人間にとってはイベントなんですね
その時は決してものだと思わないんです
間違ってでも だからちゃんと何時間やりましたとかね
高いホールとかね 借りるんだから
もうとにかく3時間以内で終了しなくちゃとかね
頑張っちゃうんです はい
それに行く前にね あの
皆様方はだいたいイベントの場合はあんまり失敗しないでしょ
仕事は失敗するわ もう家庭は失敗するわ
もう何でも失敗しますけど
友達関係失敗するわ もう何でもかんでも失敗する
体の健康維持管理は失敗するわ
しかし 何かイベントをやると
まあそんな失敗しないんですよ
だから思い浮かべてください
いろいろイベントを用意したこと過去に
ちっちゃなイベントでもいいんですよ
その時は失敗しないんです
例えば まあまあ 幼稚園でお遊戯会とか何とかありますね
それってイベントでしょ
その時は失敗やらないんです
で イベントの場合は 我々はいろんなことを計画立てて
もうこれも必要 これも必要
あれも必要とかね で 何時に飾りを作るのかどうかね
それ全部時間で全部考えて
なんとか無事イベントは成功させるんですよ
で だいたい皆様誰でも何かイベント頼んだらね
そんなに失敗しません
結構元気で もうかなり活発に頑張るんです
理由はイベントは時空なんです
だから楽しいんです やるのが
じっとしていられないんです
明日しますということはできないんです
時空 自分がもうこのイベントに
例えばもうもう おにぎり百個作ってあげると
持ってくると約束したら
日曜日九時なんです 土曜日夜寝る
寝ない 百個ですから どれぐらいご飯炊けばいいんでしょうかとかね
隣の家から炊飯器を借りてきて
炊飯器三台ぐらいやって
ちょうど時間じゃ この時間でできたらいいやといて
時間調整してちゃんと作って
それでもう五時半ぐらいに起きて
さっさとおにぎりを百個か百個さっさと作るんです
物は全部用意して で 九時だからこちら八時半に出発しないとダメだよと言うんだから
八時半になってるのを全部箱に詰めて全部分けてるんです
だから大成功 九時までに届いたら
自分のイベントは大成功
そういうことっていうのは大体失敗しない
イベントなら そういうことで
我々はなぜ人生失敗するのか
なぜ悩むのか なぜ苦しむのか
なぜ何一つもうまくいかないのかというと
問題はイベントではなくて
すべてモノでとっているんだからなんです
思考が間違っているんだからなんです
なんで間違ったかというと
怠けがあるんだからね
怠けがあるんだから 思考しないで妄想しているんです
そういう流れなんです
で 社長になりたいということで
ちょっと例え話なんです
あなたは あるいは私は社長にはなれない
社長になりたいと人が思ってもなれっこはないんです
リンゴを取るように社長の座を取れるものではありませんよ
リンゴ取り はい 社長になりたい
はい 社長になったと 社長の座を取ったつもり
例えば社長の椅子に座っているとか
で 社長になったつもり
あるいは名刺でも作る
なんだらかんだら会社の社長とか
なったつもり そんなに取れるものじゃないんですよ
あなたのイベントで社長もイベントなんです
今いるあなたも一つのイベントなんです
社長ということもものじゃないんです
ある一つのイベントなんです
今の時間で あなたはあなたというイベントは別な時間
別なあなたというイベントのイベントになるまで変化させなくてはならないんです
だから今 あなたというイベントを時間的に変化させて
変化させて変化させて
別のあなたにならなくちゃいけないんですよ
この別のあなたが社長というイベントなんです
だからあなたは社長にはなれないんです
なぜならば あなたということは
一つの今だけのイベントなんです
あの有名な何回も紹介しますけど
有名な洗脳エピソードで
あの あの ある弟子が一生懸命座禅を組んでいる
それで禅師が通っている場合はいきなり振り返ってきて
君何やっているのかと
まあ見る限り座禅しているんですけど
聞こえてもないんですけど
ただ 先生 私は座禅 座禅していますけど
あら これ何のため？と聞くんですね
あら これ何のため？だってブッダになりたいんだから
悟りたいんだから あ そう
それで禅師が何やったかというと
割れた瓦を一つ取って一生懸命磨き始めたんです
見る限りもう老師がもう捨てた瓦の破片を持って磨くと研ぐと
バカバカらしいんですね
弟子にとったらこれ見ていられないんです
先生何やってるのか 見てるんだよ
これは 何のため？鏡作るためにって言ったら
弟子が先生 いくらなんでも瓦は鏡になりませんよ
あ そう じゃあ君もね ブッダになるわけない
で それでその問題は終わるんです
座禅したって問題になるわけないんだと
そこですごい立派な方々ですよ
ものすごい簡単なことなのよ
イベントのほうを語ってるんですよ
なれないんだと ものでイベントだよということなんです
えーと これこの例でよくわかると思います
国王を毒殺すると皇太子が王になるが
皇太子か大臣かどうかはわかりません
大使だけかもしれません
わかりませんだけど 国王が毒殺されるさせると
次に皇太子が王になりますね
一般人が国王を暗殺しても大反逆者として裁かれるだけです
しかし 皇太子というイベントの次のイベントは国王です
だから毒をあげるのは息子があげたっても大丈夫ですよ
息子が父親に毒を飲ませる
で 父親が死んじゃう 父親が国王なんです
息子が大使なんです どうなるんですかね
なんのことなく国王死んだことで
では この皇太子を王位に任命せましょうと
そうなるんです なのに
同じことを一般人がやったらどうなるんですかね
王になる？なれない 大反逆者なんですね
その人を殺されるだけじゃなくて
昔のたとえ話だから この親戚みんなまとめて殺される可能性あります
なんで皇太子が国王になるのかというと
このイベントごとだからね
次のイベントは国王なんです
イベントなんです 一般の人でも反乱軍を築いて
国民の賛成を得てから国王を暗殺すれば
自分が王になる なるではなくてなれる
例えば一般人が反乱軍をあれやこれやとかかなり活動して
それでこの人の活動には国民も賛成して
この悪徳王よりはこの人は一番ありがたいんじゃないかと応答してくれて
その人が行って暗殺する
国王を暗殺したら 国民の万歳と言って
やっと悪い政治家に解放されました
あなたは今日から王様ですといいんですよ
それで考えてください
その一般人が順番にいろんなイベントをやってきたんですね
イベントごとに自分が違うものになるんですよ
一般人は一般人で 10
人ぐらいグループ集めたところで別な人格で
その10人はどんどん広げていくと
また別な人格で ではこれから武器も集めましょうというと別な人格で
それから各地方で反乱を起こしましょうと
起こして王に税金払わないことにしましょうというと
別な人格で 一般人に人気がかると
また別な人格で そういうふうに人格と人が変わって変わっていくんです
変わっていくものはイベントなんです
ものは変わりません そういうことで
これはたとえ話ね 理解できると思います
それから大きな目的に達する場合は
人生でも様々な目的に達したいと人は達したい人は
すべてはものではなく
イベントであることを理解しなければならないのです
これ間違っています 結婚披露宴
学園祭 忘年会などのイベントを成功させるやり方で取り組むんです
人生すべてに この結婚披露宴や忘年会やら学園祭などに取り込むでしょう
取り組む取り組むでしょう
その同じ取り組む形で取り組めばもったいないんです
成功する確率ははるかに高い
すべてイベントなら だから目的に達するということは大げさなことじゃないんです
お釈迦様は言うのは この愚か者にできないんだよと
怠け者にできないんだよと
それのそれだけのこと
なんで私はこのはるかに高いと書いたんですかね
で 書かないんです だからイベントだから条件いろいろありますね
私たちも時々代々木公園でなんとかあの祭りやりますけど
うまくいくと頑張りますけど
雨が降ったらね だからそういうこともありますから
それは我々が管理できることじゃない
雨が降るばっかりの恐れがあったら
それなりにまた変えればいいんです
そういうことで すべてイベントなら成功は夢の話ではないんです
それでやり方なんですけど
詳細に分解するんです
この目的を達したい目的
得たいものなどをイベントにして
それを詳細に分解するんです
分解は時間という軸で行うんです
例えば  5年で社長になる計画があるとしましょう
5年ということは  360掛ける 5で
もしかするとうるう年も入ります
1ではないんだけど 確かじゃない
2つ入る可能性もありますけど
まあ一応まあ 1826日になるんですね
それは時間で分解したんです
5年で社長になる それで今日するべきことが見えてきます
あの 忘れちゃった  1826日でしょ
今日からでしょ だから今日何をすればいいかということ
見えてきます  1日も怠けることなく
怠ることなく 今日するべきことをするんです
だから この 1300日にありますから
毎日やることだけやる
今日はこの仕事 明日は次
この仕事 怠る暇がないんです
怠ける暇がないんです
1 日目で  1713 日目でするべきことは
なんか間違ってますね
ちょっと待って ではですね
今日 1 日目ではさっぱりわかりません
まあ 1 日目始めたばっかりだから
で  1313 日目でこれやりますと思ったって
そんなのわかりません
愚か者はそれを考えて悩むんです
明日どうしよう 明後日どうしよう
明々後日どうしよう 来年どうしようと考える
悩む人は愚か者に決まっているんです
そんなのわかるものじゃないんです
ちゃんと時空で分析すると
そんな考える余裕がないんです
今日やらなくちゃいけないことがあるんです
明日はわからないんです
明日はどのような出来事が起こるかはかもわからないのです
わかるのは今日のことです
いいえ 今のことだけです
今日のことっていったって大ざっぱすぎ
今のことならわかるんです
今やるべきことは明確に知っているはずなんです
今なり 今なら何やるべきかということはあるんです
成功者は今ここで行うべきことのみを行うんです
この大成功者たちはこれやるんです
今ここで行うべき 今ここでさすがに時空間があるでしょ
今ここで行うべきことだけやるんです
すっごく楽なんです 今といえば今
ここといえば この海辺会館のホールなんです
だから駅でやるべきことは何もなくてもいいんです
場所が変わると時間も変わっています
同じ時間で 3箇所はないんです
この日々是好日という有名な仏教用語なんです
日々是好日は仏教が推薦する成功への道なんです
大解脱にさえ達する方法なので
俗世間的な目的には達することはできない
達すはありません これは日々是好日という生き方で大解脱に達しますよ
これは究極的な 一番難しい
もう生命のゴールなんです
解脱さえできるんだから
会社の社長になるぐらいはなんのこともないんです
他も俗世間のことでしょうに
なんでもできます ブッダが説かれた道を歩む人は常に成功者なんです
だからブッダに言われたとおりに歩むならば
もうその人は成功者の道を歩んでいるんです
失敗はないんです 仏道は勝利の道なんです
お釈迦様そう言うんです
これは勝利の道であると
お釈迦様は悟ったことは
我は大勝利者であると
いわゆるこの上のない勝利者であると
そういうふうに表現するんです
だからお釈迦様にある人があなたアナンタ塵でしょうとと言われた時は
アナンタっていうのは無限っていうことで
限りのない勝利者といわれて
お釈迦様そうそうそう
その通り マーディサレンジナアモンという限りのない無限の勝利者というのは
これも私のことですよ
相手が批判するつもりでしたけど
そうそう その通りです
言われていた だから仏道っていうのは勝利者の道なんです
すごいシンプルなポイントで
日々是好日という 今やるべきことをやると
常に充実した生き方だから
今ここで行うべきことを行う人は充実感を感じる
例えば今 皆様方 私の話をよくじーっと聞いていたならば
結構楽しくなっちゃいますよ
話はつらいかもしれませんだけど
よく聞いてやったと 理解したんだよと
で 自分自身で充実感感じるんです
怠けってないことで楽しみを感じる
怠け者ということはなくなっちゃうでしょ
生まれて初めて楽しみ感じるのです
ずっと我々は怠けがあるんだから
仕事をしてもどこかでやりたくないとか
歯を磨いてもどこかでできればやめたいとかあるんだから楽しみがないんです
テレビを見ていても こんなこと見ていてもアカンとかね
いつでもこの矛盾で 本当は生まれつき永遠の病気だから
病気だと気づかないだけで
あのちょっとこれ日々是好日室に入ってみたら
びっくりするほど楽しみがあふれるもんです
なんで楽しいか 考え込んだり悩んだりする暇
余裕はありません 日々是好日の人にとっては常に活発すぎる
もう活発 止まりませんから
イベントだからね だからもう前前前前という人生になるんです
活発というのはそういうことなんです
だから活発な人のアイデアも出てくるわ
もう次どうするのかっていうこといつも出てくるわ
過去にとらわれない 将来という妄想に
にではなくて 妄想の病にかからないと
その人は過去には足は引っ張られることはない
将来っていうのはやっぱり病気なんです
将来よくないことないこと
その病にかかりません
だから完全健康なんです
ブッダのこの道を選んだ
それでそのチャプターが終わる
無常と因縁という聖なる真理の何ですかね
じゃあこのチャプターからちょっと休憩挟んで始まります
はい ではあの 始まります